I think cancer research right now is
that a very interesting place.
Um,
if you think about what has happened
over the last 25 years,
it has largely been identifying the
hundred to 200,
maybe slightly more than that,
genes in the human genome that are
involved one way or another in
controlling growth.
And because cancer is fundamentally a
disease where growth is uncontrolled,
the genes that are most important in
understanding cancer are those growth
control genes.
And we're getting close to what I think
is probably a comprehensive list of
those genes.
The next step is identifying which genes
are important in which kinds of cancer.
And I think we're making real progress
there as well.
Then comes the hard part.
And the hard part is turning that
knowledge into disease specific,
uh,
cancer treatments.
We have some early examples,
success stories in this area.
Herceptin,
which was developed for the treatment of
breast cancer,
uh,
leave act,
which was developed for the treatment of
a lymphoma.
Uh,
but,
uh,
I think they're going to be many,
many more in the future.
And what's really exciting about those
therapies is unlike,
uh,
therapies that exist today,
which are largely poisons,
poisons that target dividing cells.
These new therapies are very,
very specific and target the cancer cell
itself.
And what,
that's what I mean is that those drugs
are going to be far more effective than
the drugs we use today.
And importantly,
the quality of life of the patient is
going to be significantly better because
you're not killing off hundreds of other
cells,
uh,
while you're trying to kill the cancer.
So,
okay.